we're looking down the line at AI
Automation and you're going are we not
just going to make people
millions of jobs obsolete is that not
the danger here as well all right look
about it
fully automated electric communism
um I I think and this is why uh you know
I use the c word yeah and this is why I
use the c word because I think and and
the trajectory here is 50 100 years
realistically we're looking at a
situation when
basically every human task can be
automated I think within 5200 years I
think that's I think that's quite likely
right except podcast except podcasts um
and at which point like you say that
that creates that creates massive
dysfunctions in a bunch of ways so for
instance if you have um workers who
don't have cash Capital to buy goods and
services which are made more
productively than ever before because
you have so much automation then you
have a price of what's called under the
under the price of demand or under
consumption which is you don't have
people who can buy all the goods and
services being made you know you have a
problem another issue is that the
remaining jobs that are there and which
um are captured by uniquely human sort
of characteristics those are paid better
and better and better because you can't
automate Cristiano Ronaldo or a great TV
or podcasters you can't automate those
guys right for now
um and so what that means is that
automation compresses jobs like you know
we've seen it manufacturing for decades
but I think it's going to come for
driving in a decade or two and then
basically it's going to come for
everything and so I think as a society
we have a bunch of problems there like I
say price of demand and and if we think
inequality is bad now my God you know
it's going to be even worse than 30 40
50 years time and I would also add Aaron
a crisis to meaning because jobs group
jobs bring dignity and they bring an
identity and they bring and they bring
structure well that's why I use this and
that's why I use the c word because this
is a profound challenged capitalism it's
a profound challenge capitalism and I
think we need to be honest about that
because you know the economists did a
great line about this in 2013 they said
what happens when Capital becomes labor
which is to say there is no distinction
between capital and labor once you can
automate pretty much everything and that
we might not see it I think we probably
will our children will see it and and so
what's the sort of political economic
settlement when that happens you know I
I it doesn't look like capitalism it
doesn't look like capitalism as we know
it so that's why I use the c word no but
controversial the thing is I don't think
I I don't know about Francis I certainly
don't disagree that in a world where no
one has to work it sort of doesn't make
sense that the people who historically
have held the capital now own everything
and no one else has anything in a world
where no one needs to work and
everything is done by robots a system of
Distributing resources fairly equally in
that world is great actually I think I'm
sure there's counter arguments to that
that I probably haven't considered but
I'm open to that but what Francis was
asking was something else which is in
the interim because you know we're all
going to live in that interim 100 years
right there's quite a lot of human lives
in that when you when you raise wages
what you are doing is you're
incentivizing those jobs out of
existence yeah right and so isn't there
a counterproductive element to some of
those drives for higher wages in certain
industries yes there's a guy he just
died actually a guy called Mario tronte
he was a Marxist Italian uh sort of
thinker and he said exactly this so
historically people have always thought
Innovation is driven by capitalists
right you know yeah great levels of
automation new Innovations to create
things more productively he says no it's
created by workers and struggle them
struggling for better work better paying
conditions more money is the is the
Catalyst for better Innovation right
because that leads to like the things
you create incentives yeah you I mean
this is the literally like page one or
two of The Wealth of Nations right so I
think I think again even if you even if
you're not on the left if you want a
high productivity high performance
economy
there's the argument for higher wages
because you're going to create
incentives for businesses to
um increase productivity use more fixed
Capital hold on you care about the
working people you want to automate
their jobs out of existence no no but if
you look if you have if you have working
class representation you have Labor
organizations and the state is on their
side they can be reallocated to other
parts of the labor market they can be
retrained or you can say look the
evidence is very poor on people being
retrained no I agree with you well in an
aging population we probably will need
to retrain some people to to help you
know with regards to healthy care work
for instance I don't mean like uh
retrain design an app that's I
agree with you there but on on things
like I think I mean really demographic
aging so I think in the US
over 50 of the sort of the the jobs
which are are growing significantly are
in relation to health and Elderly Care
Services because we're getting older as
a society we're having fewer babies and
people are living longer generally
speaking
um so I suppose the quick answer is in
the interim what do we do I think
there's a bunch of challenges in the
21st century that we need to uh take
head-on in to borrow a phrase from kirst
armor a mission oriented sense I agree
with that
um I think one is demographic aging I
think another is the housing crisis and
I think a third is climate change now
people might be watching this going oh
climate change look at the weather
outside globally speaking it's a huge
challenge particularly for sort of
countries to our South they're going to
really struggle
um and I think you know we're going to
have to gear up to a world which looks
very different to today so those will be
what I say we need to use the dividend
of technological change to human genius
to address those challenges in the
interim because like you say full
automation is is decades away